[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reportero soy marina colorado por ángela
gutiérrez colombia ha protagonizado los
titulares de medios internacionales en
estas últimas semanas sin embargo el
mensaje que quiere lanzar la ciudadanía
colombiana lleva presente décadas las
protestas son la manera que tiene la
sociedad de llamar la atención de su
gobierno tras años de abandono y éstas
son tan solo la punta del iceberg
nuestros compañeros
luís muñoz y ahora va a jude estuvieron
viajando por el suroeste del país y nos
acompañan en el estudio bienvenidos
louis cuéntanos estos tres departamentos
por los que han estado viajando
concentran muchas de las problemáticas
que tiene tanto la sociedad colombiana
como en concreto el campo colombiano
cómo fue este viaje así es marina el
foco mediático principalmente los medios
lo pusimos en las ciudades en las
protestas que empezaron en colombia el
pasado 28 de abril pero también ha
habido protestas en el territorio y eso
es lo que nos hemos preguntado de france
24 que ha pasado allá entonces hemos
iniciado un viaje de 10 días que nos ha
llevado desde el putumayo frontera con
ecuador también pasando por nariño y
terminando en el cauca
son un total de siete ciudades múltiples
veredas y todo ha sido gracias a la
asociación minga que nos ha brindado
acompañamiento en todos estos días pues
dejemos entonces que las imágenes hablen
por sí mismas
en el resguardo de páez corinto sale el
arco iris coincide con el entierro de
una profesora de gobernadora indígena
ariannys sata que fue asesinada junto a
su esposo ambos pertenecían a la etnia
nasa uno de los más de 100 grupos
étnicos de colombia desde el 28 de abril
inicio del paro nacional han matado a 6
miembros de los pueblos originarios en
el departamento del cauca al sur
occidente de colombia sus autoridades
denuncian una alianza entre el estado y
los múltiples grupos armados ilegales
que buscan ocupar el espacio liberado
por la guerrilla de las farc con los
acuerdos de paz del año 2016
yo creo que el conflicto
se agudizó precisamente entonces hay una
lucha entre narcoparamilitarismo y
estado puntos acá y gobierno contra el
movimiento indígena en el cauca y en
colombia y esos dos poderes están
disputando el territorio
estos con armas y muertes no otros con
bastón palabra liberación de la madre
tierra con sabiduría y con la
ancestralidad el departamento del cauca
junto a nariño y putumayo forman el
suroccidente colombiano
en 2019 de los 32 departamentos del país
sólo estos tres sumaban el 51% de
cultivos de coca de colombia según la
oficina de las naciones unidas contra la
droga y el delito el control de la coca
continúa pese a los acuerdos de paz en
una guerra por el territorio que pone en
peligro a las comunidades indígenas su
protagonismo en el paro nacional ha
aumentado el riesgo así lo demuestra el
asesinato de la gobernadora pero también
los presagios ancestrales para los
indígenas nasa el arco iris significa
que va a haber más derramamiento de
sangre
un derramamiento de sangre que no ha
afectado exclusivamente a los indígenas
decenas de personas han muerto en las
protestas también en los territorios
entonces ya sea ningún primo y dejando
una tragedia primo me los quitaron
giordani
yo no lo podía creer
él es juan rosero padre de jordan y
joven de 21 años de la vereda de la
castellana en el departamento del
putumayo era estudiante de ingeniería
civil de la universidad del cauca y
participaba en las marchas de la ciudad
de villagarzón donde campesinos e
indígenas se tomaron una perforación
petrolífera su objetivo era protestar
contra el extractivismo sus
consecuencias medioambientales y el nulo
impacto económico en sus vidas el lunes
31 de mayo la unidad de antinarcóticos
bajo el pretexto de que los
manifestantes querían tomarse las
instalaciones policiales actuó contra la
protesta una bala atravesó el tórax de
giordani
que lo que queremos es que se
esclarezcan los hechos y que la fuerza
pública en este caso los anti narcóticos
se hagan responsables y que las
responsabilidades sigan subiendo hasta
que la máxima autoridad que es el
presidente que es en última el que da
las órdenes de esta situación la familia
rosero se dedica al cultivo del
chontaduro una fruta tropical que dan
este tipo de palmas está o no la siembra
esta palma ya los 4 años aproximadamente
ya sabe de producción a pesar del riesgo
y la dureza es la actividad principal en
la zona también para uber medardo líder
indígena y buen amigo de giordani
está la otra aquí donde tengo yo la mano
en esa mano está es donde yo me siento
me siento entre los deseos para una vida
vivible están peticiones tan básicas
como carreteras dignas y por a veces
malas condiciones las carreteras
en muy mal estado se dificulta él
el transportar el producto vías en las
que no se siente el dinero de las
regalías que dejan las empresas
extractivistas
poder dedicarse a un cultivo lícito es
un privilegio de ovando cruces líder de
la vereda de la cumbre a tres horas de
puerto asís en la frontera con ecuador
ha estado ayudando en los bloqueos de la
ciudad junto a veredas que no
acostumbraban a protestar y que incluso
habían confiado en el gobierno actual
porque lo apoyamos y ve a donde los
tiene
conociendo los pegó a la puñalada
la mayoría de los campesinos de la zona
trabajan con la planta de coca esta les
permite unas condiciones de vida mínimas
impensables con otros cultivos viven en
territorios agrícolas muy fértiles pero
para sacar los productos necesitan un
animal de carga una barca para cruzar el
río putumayo y un coche los costes son
prohibitivos mientras que la coca vienen
a comprarse la directamente a casa no
tenemos cómo sacar nuestros productos y
por eso nos vemos obligado siembra la
mate coca porque no hay otra alternativa
con abajo vivir la erradicación de
plantas mediante la aspersión de
glifosato es uno de los planes del
gobierno los campesinos temen que los
efectos del químico les dejen sin
trabajo sin comida y sin salud
trabajando de o val d'or raspa coca
desde los 12 años en el momento de la
grabación vende el gramo a 50 céntimos
de dólar 300 veces menos de lo que se
paga en el mercado estadounidense que
nosotros somos los que menos ganamos
porque para sostener a mataco canasta
que invertirle mucho con los acuerdos de
paz del 2016
miles de familias firmaron el compromiso
de erradicar sus cultivos pero los
proyectos estatales de sustitución nunca
llegaron las plantaciones han vuelto de
forma masiva y los narcotraficantes
acuden a las veredas a comprar el
producto nuestro equipo no puede
acompañar adeudado a sus plantaciones su
vida correría peligro en 2019 en una
protesta recibió un impacto de perdigón
por parte de la policía perdió el ojo
izquierdo
[Aplausos]
para evitar represalias muchas personas
optan por el desplazamiento colombia es
el país con más desplazados internos del
mundo con cerca de 8 millones
víctor armero es diputada en la asamblea
del cauca líder campesino que hasta hace
dos años raspaba coca en el municipio de
argelia allí todos los concejales están
desplazadas la tasa de homicidios es de
125 por 100.000 habitantes el precio de
la coca ha aumentado un cien por cien y
con diez mil hectáreas es el principal
lugar de producción de coca del pacífico
colombiano los grupos armados vuelven a
controlar el territorio la promesa del
acuerdo de paz se ha esfumado
yo tuve la oportunidad en el 2012 de ser
secretario de gobierno de mi municipio
la guerrilla atacó alrededor de 87 veces
en el 2012
ataques constantes casi días por medio
cuando se primó el presente pase eso se
redujo a cero por eso que diga alguien
que por ese pan no ha servido es porque
no ha estado dentro del conflicto pero
nosotros que hemos estado en conflicto
el proceso de paz fue una bendición los
niños poder jugar en la calle los niños
poder salir al parque el recrudecimiento
del conflicto obliga a víctor a
permanecer en popayán capital del
departamento no puede volver a casa
hasta que le asignen un esquema de
seguridad aprovecha para acompañar a los
puntos de resistencia de la ciudad
nacidos el 28 de abril con el inicio del
paro nacional después del primer mes de
protestas se han convertido en asambleas
permanentes donde se organizan
actividades como este partido de fútbol
la violencia vista en el paro nacional
no es nueva para los campesinos y
obviamente para la gente ya es costumbre
la violencia ya la gente aprendió a
convivir de esa forma y claro el boom y
el escándalo a nivel incluso
internacional es porque kevin se
desplazó a la ciudad y eso fue un
poquito eso no es nada con lo que pasa
en el campo
para armero el cumplimiento del punto 1
del acuerdo de paz que establece una
reforma rural integral ayudaría a que
los jóvenes de las ciudades también
encuentren una salida a la precariedad
urbana
para hablar sobre los problemas en estos
departamentos nos recibe el general
fernando murillo director de la dijín la
policía judicial y de inteligencia de
colombia no quiere responder a las
acusaciones de violencia policial y de
connivencia con grupos armados y nuestro
deber está en investigar ese tipo de
denuncias cuando lo sean
y lo que siempre decimos si hay una
responsabilidad de un miembro de la
fuerza pública actuando ilegalmente pues
también le caerá el peso de la ley entre
las investigaciones del general murillo
está el narcotráfico reconoce que
indígenas afrodescendientes y campesinos
son los más afectados entonces una
realidad la confrontación y la violencia
que tienen que vivir estas poblaciones y
uno lo que pide es que cada día tienen
que entender y tienen que confiar más en
la institucionalidad poblaciones que
están en medio de un conflicto que
continúa el combustible
y realmente de estas organizaciones
siempre ha sido el narcotráfico y detrás
del narcotráfico insisto que donde se ha
generado esa violencia que vive el país
por más de 50 años me pegaron cinco
tiros una guerra contra las drogas
impulsada hace 50 años por el presidente
de eeuu richard nixon y de improbable
final
pero además de ser uno de los mayores
productores de coca los cultivos lícitos
tratan de resistir contra el auge de los
cultivos ilícitos colombia es conocido
como el país cafetero rubio ordóñez es
una lideresa de san pablo- en el
departamento de nariño ha estado
participando en el paro
los campesinos cafeteros llevan décadas
soñando con mejores condiciones es decir
lo que no se imagina del niño
bueno vendrán tiempos mejores y sin
embargo pues uno siente como que se
alejan esas posibilidades y mucha gente
incluso se murió esperando tiempos
mejores sino entre sus deseos mejores
vías soberanía alimentaria mayor
posesión de tierras y la posibilidad de
desarrollar su actividad un mensaje que
tuve transmite a las más jóvenes es la
educadora de una escuelita para futuras
lideresas campesinas pues ustedes
conocen que el tema del café es una de
las líneas de económicas que sostiene
pues a las familias nos está acompañada
de dos de sus alumnas dicta la lección
desde la procesadora que tiene la
comunidad aquí produce en su café el
alto lo que lo que quisiéramos
preguntarles es
quisieran ser ustedes cuando cuando sean
adultas yo quisiera ser un tipo de
generación donde
es donde campesina se reconozca más
sujeto
para vivir el arraigo de los jóvenes es
clave para la supervivencia del campo
colombiano
pero también el empoderamiento de las
más jóvenes y cuando vemos a las niñas
atrás de nosotras
copiando estos procesos de formación
estas prácticas y ese sueño de vida esas
formas de vida pues creemos que hay
esperanzas de que un día también sea las
matriarcas no las que las que puedan
dirigir y sostener este país
es de las cuales resistencias en el
campo colombiano que no se pueden
entender sin el amor por la madre tierra
también conocida entre los pueblos
originarios andinos como pachamama el
taita marcelino es líder medicinal en la
comunidad indígena inga junto a la etnia
causa habitan los resguardos de sibundoy
en las montañas del departamento del
putumayo
marcelino enseña su huerta donde de cada
planta cultiva un conocimiento ancestral
esta ortega
cuando tomamos el viaje se pierden el
viaje es una bebida ancestral se prepara
con dos plantas y tiene propiedades
alucinógenas su consumo está rodeado de
un sofisticado ritual para los indígenas
es un viaje de conexión espiritual y
también política
el taita chucho es la autoridad de
gobierno lleva siendo 13 años alumno de
marcelino espera el momento de
convertirse en paita medicinal usted es
una persona que que es un ejemplo para
nosotros como taita el taita chucho
suele pedir consejo al taita marcelino y
al viaje en este paro tras consultar con
la planta sagrada los signos decidieron
unirse a las protestas yo a través de la
de la planta
como para darme cuenta de las de las
políticas
qué es lo que piensa que lo que van a
hacer que lo que a dónde están los
corruptos están uno dentro del viaje uno
se da cuenta todo
una esfera política que va de la mano de
la tradición las comunidades indígenas
milenarias luchan por impedir su propia
extinción en el complejo sur occidente
colombiano donde el narcotráfico ha
despojado de significado hasta su
ancestral hoja de coca sin embargo
mediante rituales como este los incas
logran articular a su comunidad mientras
conectan con su principal objeto de
defensa la madre tierra
como mencionábamos al inicio también nos
acompaña aurora valle ella es periodista
de france 24 y fue la camarógrafa de
este reportaje
aurora cuál es el principal problema que
os habéis encontrado en esta parte del
país bueno para sólo mencionar uno y
creo que a mí es lo que más me
impresionó es la falta de reforma
agraria es el primer punto de los
acuerdos de paz de 2016 y sin embargo
los campesinos la siguen esperando
estuvimos con muchos viajando con ellos
y nos pudimos dar cuenta que por ejemplo
las vías están en un estado crítico y
eso pues les impide sacar su producto
del campo para llevarlo a donde pues lo
podrían vender por ejemplo una señora
nos estaba contando que ya cultiva piña
y no los no las puede llevar al mercado
entonces las tienen que regalar a sus
gallinas también muchos campesinos nos
decían que los procesos de sustitución
de cultivos ilícitos están muy lentos en
esta región
por eso no tienen otros remedios que
seguir cultivando esa hoja de coca y
lluís finalmente cuál es la relación
entre lo que ustedes han visto este
contexto y el paro nacional en colombia
lo decía el diputado víctor armero de la
asamblea del cauca en el reportaje lo
que se ha visto y que ha hecho tan
mediático internacionalmente el
conflicto del paro nacional ha sido como
la violencia que han vivido
históricamente los campesinos en el
territorio se ha visto en las ciudades y
se han visto en videos también en en
redes sociales por lo tanto es las
demandas pueden ser diferentes entre
ciudad y campo y los campesinos
indígenas y afrodescendientes de lo que
se quejan en el cauca en el putumayo y
en nariño es de la violencia constante
que viene por una disputa por el control
territorial derivada del narcotráfico
sin embargo cabe destacar algo que nos
ha llamado la atención y es como todos
los minutos los manifestantes tanto
jóvenes estudiantes campesinos indígenas
todos nos han dicho que están un poco
agradecidos al gobierno de cómo han sido
su reacción para poder haberse unido en
este paro nacional que empezó el 28 de
abril
vamos pues muchísimas gracias luis una
vez más bis muñoz
aurora valle por este reportaje y a
ustedes recordarles que pueden volver a
ver todas las emisiones de reporteros de
nuestro sitio web para 94 puntocom
[Música]